all right seven minutes down after the
hour let's bring in house minority
leader kevin mccarthy who sent a letter
to the president biden to do something
about the border and this immigration
crisis it is a crisis uh leader do you
melita mccarthy welcome do you expect to
get any response or is this like
spitting in the wind
i hope to get a response and we won't
shut up i mean i've listened to this
president say he's been in office for
more than 40 years but they never can
prove one time that he's even been to
the border more than two-thirds of the
republicans in congress have been to the
border just this year so we'd like to
sit down with him if he's too busy to
get there because the challenge is what
is happening it's making every city in
america a border city fentanyl has
increased by more than 300 percent
killing americans you watch the cartels
where i just had a round table just last
week with mayors from these cities down
there they've had to close their schools
42 different days just this year because
of the crime that came across in the
high-speed chases and now what we're
finding we are catching people on the
terrorist watch list so this is not just
central america more than 150 other
countries we have caught people that
came from yemen not on the same day but
on different days why are they coming to
america who are they working with and
what do they have planned this is about
the security of our country and the
president says he is too busy to deal
with it we'd like to sit down with him
talk about the facts and solve this
problem once and for all when we saw
these images yesterday we were all just
floored because thousands of them are
heading toward our border it's a huge
crowd somewhere in wheelchairs some kids
were in strollers families coming up
i know many of republicans are worried
about mass amnesty these alarming
numbers and then we saw thousands of
them busting through the mexico national
guard are we worried that's going to
happen when they come to america
well if they won't abide by the law
enforcement there why do we think they'd
abide by it in america america one of
the greatest strengths we have is the
rule of law we believe in an illegal
immigration system but when you break
society down you break over the law that
creates tremendous amount of problems in
our country and this president is
ignoring it remember this isn't the
first time a caravan is coming this
isn't the first time he's been warned
ahead of time and then he lied to
america that he was sending people back
home no in the dead of night he sent
them around the country
right remember we're in the middle of
covet as well with no one's being tested
absolutely and they're letting all those
thousands of people in and at the same
time leader mccarthy you know so they're
letting thousands of people into our
country but at the same time with these
government mandates on vaccines they're
firing cops and firefighters left and
right but they're letting these people
in and also yesterday the news was that
if you're from a country there are 50
different countries where the
vaccination rate is like less than 10
percent
the federal government says if you've
got a compelling reason we're going to
let you in because we want to restart
this international travel thing it seems
like there's a double standard for in
international people and for people who
work here
i don't understand these first
responders were our heroes last year
that worked in there when there wasn't a
vaccine now you want to fire them and
allow other people into the country
illegally who could have covet and
spread it throughout the country by not
even telling the mayors of those cities
that you're bringing them into your city
this is what's wrong and backwards and
if the president does not have time to
go understand what's happening along the
border us who have been there would love
to sit down with them to work together
to solve this problem that's what our
government is designed to do to find the
compromise we spent our time there we
understand it let's bring the border
agents who watch this every day who have
been pushed beyond means about what
they've had to work through and let them
explain what's going on
but
glitter mccarthy he has no interest in
solving this problem that's the issue
it's not that you have different views
one leaves the door open and one is
trying to strategize to organize who
comes in and out and they're leaving the
door open and they're ignoring it so i
think the whole thing is fruitless until
you guys find a way to get back the
house in the white house meanwhile let's
talk about what's happening because you
lost the house and the senate and the
white house nancy pelosi has an agenda
and the democrats social spending
through the roof and even though they're
having trouble with their own caucus
they look like they're going to get
something across to the tune of between
1.5 and 2 trillion dollars and the
reason why they're struggling according
to the speaker it's because the media is
not selling their plan remember this
last week
latest cbs news poll shows that only
about 10 of americans describe
themselves as knowing a lot of specific
things that are in the reconciliation
package and that the majority don't know
anything at all so do you think you need
to do a better job at messaging and
going forward how do you sell this well
i think you all could do a better job of
selling it to be very frank with you
because every time i come here i go
through the list it's hard to break
through
when you have such a comprehensive
package
right so it's the media's fault so cnn
realized they were wrong so they quickly
changed it and they have now an article
on cnn.com get up to speed how the
spending bill would change your life so
they're helping out they finally got on
the same page wouldn't you look wouldn't
you love to have a compliant media like
that
i i would love that but remember what's
in this bill 200 million dollars for a
park in pelosi's district you know she's
on her farewell to her everyone knows
she's in europe and she comes back in
the in this bill is also
amnesty for about 10 million illegal
immigrants that you watch coming across
this border won't the parliamentarians
strike that down
i don't know if they will or not but
it's in the dim it's in the democrat
bill today that they want to pass inside
the house remember what the american
public is saying just in a recent poll
that we are on the wrong direction the
top two issues was inflation and why is
inflation here because of the spending
of what the democrats have done the
trillions of dollars you watch what
they're doing every day you watch on
your news the supply chain the most
expensive thanksgiving we've ever had
the price of gas even in one place in
california is over seven dollars our
shelves when we go into our stores you
don't believe it's america where we do
not have our shelves or become empty
it's based upon the democratic policies
and the second top issue
was the immigration and our border the
democrats are headed in the wrong
direction but it's not just the price of
the bill it's the provisions that are in
it don't get hung up that oh it's less
money it's not less money all the
democrats are saying is they won't fund
it as many years but it will still be a
program that gets funded by government
that will break us in the system leader
mccarthy uh the democrats now are
talking about to pay for it they would
have like a uh a trillionaire tax or
something like that billionaire a
trillionaire ultimately it's gonna
it's gonna take involve about 700 people
but what they're doing is a lot of
people are saying it can't possibly be
constitutional because what they're
saying is we're going to tax you
on unrealized capital gains
if you haven't sold it it's not income
and if you have a bad year is the
federal government government going to
give you that money back if you're a
trillionaire the next year
no
remember it's not just people out there
that are saying it's illegal even the
democratic chairman of ways and means
said he looked at it and has been
illegal remember what the socialist
countries in europe have done they
imposed a wealth tax and france germany
and sweden pulled it back because they
realized it doesn't work remember
america has tried this before
alternative minimum tax that only went
in with a with a handful of americans
had to pay at the wealthiest and what
happened as years progressed millions of
those in the middle class had to pay for
it remember what else is in this bill 85
000 irs agents and remember they say
it's going after the wealthy but if you
make 28 a day they're going after you
and you know what the number 85 000 is
that's larger than the population of
scranton pennsylvania the hometown of
this president and what are they going
to spend their time on going after you
and
don't think oh i'm not a millionaire
they won't come after me yes they are if
you spend 28 dollars a day they're
coming after you and they're valuing
what you have the irs and we know it's
an incentive for them to make the value
higher just to tax you whether you sell
it or not or whatever the value is that
is not the america we believe in that is
not the american that the constitution
says that's why we are fighting and we
need people to join with us because we
only need four democrats to say no to
stop this
good luck
thank you for coming on with us
thank you you're welcome i'm steve ducey
i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis